Đây, em đang làm, nó đang hơi không kiểm soát được, thì em cũng đề tài của em là em sẽ cố gắng sử dụng GAN trong...
Vâng, em có, nên em biết tiếng Anh, tại vì em quên chân đổi đã, thì em dùng GAN để tấn công SQL.
Thì đây là mục tiêu
Thì là, này anh ơi là bài toán
Thì là hiện tại là
Giữ liệu thì sẽ hầu hết sẽ là
Các giữ liệu của người dùng rất bình thường
Đôi lúc mới có giữ liệu tấn công ấy
Thì tỷ lệ sẽ rơi khoảng từ 100 trên 1
Thì tới 1000 trên 1
Thì theo phương pháp bình thường thì mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là
Lọc giữ liệu rồi
Chuyển hoàn thành vector có thể dùng
MOT, SMOT để kiểu
Định dạng lại thì lúc này
Mình sẽ dùng GAN bởi vì GAN nó có thể học
Còn cái thằng kia nó chỉ đơn giản nội sinh, nghĩa là mình đưa cho nó cái gì thì nó cũng chỉ thay đổi các string
Nó chỉ học nội sinh thôi, nó không có khả năng sinh ra những cái dữ liệu mới để mình có thể học tiếp
Thế em mới đề xuất ra, thì đây là mô hình của em ạ
Thì là đầu tiên là em sẽ lấy dữ liệu, là lấy dữ liệu trên cargo và một số cái data
Lấy thêm dữ liệu của các cái CVR, nghĩa là những người ta ghi nhận những cái tần công
Vâng, dữ liệu thì em lấy, em cũng chỉ lấy khoảng 30.000vnd bởi vì dữ liệu tấn công thực tế
Khi mà em làm thì em thấy là hầu hết là nó chỉ là noise, nghĩa là nó chỉ có khả năng tấn công
Thứ nhất là lúc mà em gõ thật thì khả năng tấn công thực tế của nó là không có, nó khá là ít, này em mới nhận ra
Thì còn tiếp theo là em sẽ cho mô hình nó sẽ có hai thành phần
Đầu tiên là thành phần Generate và thành phần Quality và thành phần Featix
Thì em có thêm vào là trong này là sẽ có thêm một
Thì trong này vần này em sẽ có thêm cái Mutation
Nghĩa là em sẽ cho nó biết định nghĩa về các cho cả hai thằng
Cái này là em cũng mới tìm hiểu
Thì em đang hiểu là em sẽ cho nó biết là
Bây giờ SQN Action thì nó sẽ phải có những điều kiện tối thiểu là gì
Em cho cả hai thằng nó học luôn
Còn nếu mà làm theo cách bình thường thì nó đang hơi loạn
Sau khi mà critic thành công xong em sẽ có thêm một lớp để check nữa
Thì nó sẽ gồm 3 cái
Đầu tiên là kiểm tra xem có phải là SQL không là cái L1
Tiếp theo là sẽ kiểm tra xem là khả năng injection của nó
nghĩa là xem là thực tế nó có khả năng tấn công không
Hiện tại là em mới chỉ cho quét qua bộ thư viện
open-source ở trên mạng
Còn cái số 3 là em sẽ quét xem là độ đa dạng
xem là nó có thật sự đa dạng như là nó có thật sự hơn được
Thay thế được m... thay được hàng smooth luôn ạ
Thì trong tương lai thì em sẽ thay thế cái thằng L2 bằng cách em cho tấn công thực tế trên các tương lửa thông dụng ạ.
Và cái cuối cùng là các cái thước đo để xem là mô hình của em đạt những gà trị nào.
Thì đây là kết quả, nếu như mà tỷ lệ mà rất rất cân bằng như 500 trên 1 ạ, cái cỗ ngoài cùng ạ.
Thì là nó thì cái môi xét gan nó sẽ hơn được cái phương pháp cơ bản là 42%
Nhưng mà càng lên cao thì nếu mà tỷ lệ càng thấp thì thằng 1 nó sẽ thắng được thằng gan
Thì tỷ lệ đây em chọn là 100%
Em cho rằng tỷ lệ mất cân bằng đủ để mình có thể dùng phương pháp gan
Nhờ hình bên phải, em cũng thử chia ra 4 trường hợp, trong tấn công SQL sẽ có 4 trường hợp.
2 trường hợp đầu tiên là Boolean và Error. Cái này là dựa trên phản hồi của máy chủ.
Nó không thực sự tấn công, nó sẽ đợi xem phản hồi máy chủ và từ đó họ sẽ mường tượng xem hệ thống của môi nhà như thế nào.
thì nên là hai cái đầu nó sẽ không có đặc biệt
bởi vì nó chỉ đơn giản là tấn công những cái mà mình đã biết rồi ạ
nhưng mà hai cái cuối cùng là sẽ...